your chairman has a firm belief that
owners are entitled to hear directly
from the CEO as to what is going on and
how he evaluates the business currently
and prospectively you would demand that
in a private company you should expect
no less in a public company
our goal is modest we simply attempt to
be fearful when others are greedy and to
only be greedy when others are fearful
after 25 years of buying and supervising
a great variety of businesses we have
not learned how to solve difficult
business problems what we've learned is
to avoid them if past history was all
there was to the game then the richest
people would be librarians we've long
felt that the only value of stock
forecasters is to make fortune tellers
look good if the choice is between a
questionable business at a comfortable
price or a comfortable business a
questionable price we prefer the ladder
ladder not ladder
nothing sedates rationality like large
doses of effortless money whether we're
talking about socks or stocks I like
buying quality merchandise when it is
marked down you only find out who's
swimming naked when the tide goes out
bubble is blown large enough they
eventually pump if horses had controlled
investment decisions there would have
been no auto industry don't ask the
barber whether you need a haircut
you